starting with traffic because freeways
here in town are just filling up like
they usually do but heads up northbound
i-15 completely shut down after gene so
friday's a big day for folks from
southern california to come spend the
weekend with us up in southern nevada
here's what happened about 2 45 this
morning unconfirmed that a wrong-way
driver was southbound in the northbound
lanes and went head-on into this
semi-tractor trailer that caught fire
but miraculously no fatalities but the
road is still closed we have our own
photographer on the scene armando
showing us that one of those cars we
believe it was a pickup truck on the
back of a flatbed tow to get out of
there meantime drivers are being
diverted onto las vegas boulevard so
it's not as bad as it might be with the
complete closure of the freeway las
vegas boulevard is right next door
you're being diverted off and the
boulevard goes right by the seven magic
mountains rock sculptures all the way
into town so while the freeway is closed
it's not as bad as it might be meantime
we'll keep an eye on the freeways and
the surface streets and keeping an eye
on the forecast